the Joe Rogan experience meditation yeah
yes I mean that's it works it's it's
been a lifesaver for me oh I do it and I
I do it whenever I get like spare time I
was in the doctor's office this morning
and I knew it was gonna be twenty
minutes so I just sat there with my eyes
closed for twenty minutes and I
meditated you know when I was growing up
there was this statement I think it was
Pascal he said you know all of man's
problems arise because he cannot sit by
himself in a room for thirty minutes
alone hmm and it's very true I always
needed to be stimulated and when the
iPhone came along boredom was dead I
would never be bored again
even if I'm standing in line I'm on my
iPhone and I thought it was great and
when I was a kid I used to try and
overclock my brain be like how many
thoughts can I think it wants the answer
is only one but I would try to think
multiple thoughts at once and I was
proud of that I was proud that my brain
was always running this engine was
always moving and it's a disease it's
actually the road to misery and now that
I'm older I realize like you actually
want to again rest your mind you want to
learn how to settle into your mind now I
look forward to solitary confinement you
leave me alone for a day it'll be like
the happiest day I've had in a while
hmm and and that is a superpower that I
think everybody can attain the
superpower of learning to be alone and
enjoying it yeah yeah well I think it's
critical and I and I do think that this
there's these times where you just think
about things just be alone and think
about things are so rare these days and
I think during those rare times is when
you really get to understand what you
actually believe or don't believe yeah
it's it's funny when I first started
meditating it was really hard right
because everybody I think a lot of
people who were listeners broadcast have
heard of meditation that has a good rep
so everybody tries it this struggle they
kind of give it up it's one of those
things that everybody says they do but
nobody actually does right it's like not
eating sugar right everyone talks about
how yeah I don't need sugar but like
yeah then right then the dessert tray
rolls around and everyone's going for
the cookies yeah right yeah so it's
become one of those things and in fact
it's now even become a signaling thing
where it's like oh how much did you
meditate this much or you know there are
people now wearing headband saying with
tweed birds are chirpin then when
they're in deep
I don't know I don't know how they make
it work but they'll be like I got a lot
of trips today how many trips did you
get oh my god oh your meditation
technique is wrong mine is right
but really all it is is the art of doing
nothing okay and it's important because
I think when we when we grow up right
it's all this stuff happening to you in
your life and some of it you're
processing some of it you're absorbing
and some of it you should probably think
a little bit more about and work through
but you don't you don't have time so it
gets buried in you and it's all these
preferences and judgements and
unresolved situations and issues and
it's like your email inbox it's just
piling up email after email after email
that's not answered going back 10 20 30
40 years and then when you sit down to
meditate those emails start coming back
at you hey what about this issue what
about that issue have you solved this do
you think about that your regrets there
you have issues there and that gets
scary people don't want to do that's
like it's not working I can't clear my
mind
I better get up and not do this but
really what's happening is this it's
it's self therapy it's just that instead
of paying a therapist to sit they don't
listen to you do this link to yourself
and you just have to sit there as those
emails go through one by one you work
through each of them until you get to
the magical inbox zero and there comes a
day when you sit down you realize the
only things you're thinking about are
the things that happen yesterday because
you've processed everything else not
necessary even resolved it but at least
listen to yourself and that's when
meditation starts and I think it's a
it's a very powerful thing that
everybody should experience and that's
when you arrive upon the art of doing
nothing well I think it's even a problem
that most people are getting their
meditation from an app I will not use an
app it's sneaky I mean sam harris is a
very good meditation app I should say
that but you should be able to just do
it and many people can it is literally
the art of doing nothing yes all you
need to do for meditation is just sit
down close your eyes comfortable
position whatever happens happens if you
think you think if you don't think you
don't think don't put it over into it
don't put effort against it all you need
do you concentrate on your breath or do
you have a specific technique nothing
okay no you sit you just sit I think
about my breath that's all I do I just
need to try to only concentrate on
breathing I used to do that but it's
some level all the concentration every
meditation technique is leading you to
the same thing which is just witnessing
yeah and concentration is a technique to
steal your mind enough that you can then
drop the object of concentration so you
could also just try going straight to
the endgame the problem with what I'm
talking about which is not focusing on
your breath is you will have to listen
to your mind for a long time it's not
gonna work unless you do at least an
hour a day and preferably at least 60
days before you kind of work through a
lot of issues so it'll be held for a
while but when you come out the other
side it's great you get rid of the
chatter or when the chatter comes it's
in the background
it's dimmer it's smaller you've heard it
before you see the patterns it's more
recent it's something you need to
resolve anyway and you will get moments
of actual silence what is your what's
your ultimate state when you meditate
like is there a state where you've
achieved rarely if ever where you just
you you you're in bliss or you're in
harmony or you're in enlightenment like
whether it's time it's kind of
indescribable because when you're really
meditating you're not there when there's
no thoughts there's no experience or
there's nothing there's just nothing so
it's it's hard to describe but I would
say that it's like a you could
definitely in every psychedelic state
that people encounter using so called
plant medicines can be arrived at just
through pure meditation and I've
definitely hit some of those states
you've hit some transcendent psychedelic
states where you're meeting the whole
deal had trippy visuals I've had the
kind of the lights in color the
so-called downloads I've had the
realizations I've had the bliss I've had
the light the colors but not every time
no it's really and in fact I would say
that that that's a that's also like an
experience that you can start craving
which will then actually take you out of
meditation mm-hmm were you really
and I'm not enlightened or anything
close to it so not even the ballpark but
my own experience and this is this
personal experience is the place where I
end up the most that is really the one
that I I want to be at is peace mmm
it's just peace peace happy